this is going to be some kind of a night
to make your major league debut and
that's the assignment for the youngster
eli morgan 5 10 190 pounds he's 25 years
old
not a hard thrower normally in the low
90s
he also features a curved slider and
many feel the best
change up in the indians organization
beauvoishette
didn't mean to but he checks his swing
out in front of the plate
morgan has to hurry and they just get
him by a whisker
eli's family on hand watch him make his
major league debut
well you can see he gets off the mound
in a hurry because it wasn't that far
out in front of home plate
just barely gets best at first base t
oscar hernandez
and the right-hander fire slows it down
hit high in the air i want to see what
this wind does there
naylor move those feet baby keep him
moving he makes the grab
and the side is retired his family loves
it a scoreless first for eli morgan
the cleveland lineup will face yunjin
ryu tonight making his tenth start of
the season seventh time he's pitched on
the road he threw the ball very well as
last time out against tampa cesar
hernandez is at third jose ramirez at
second harold ramirez at first
and eddie rosario and the 2-1 pitch line
in the right center field of base hit
that'll score cesar
here comes jose ramirez he will score on
his way to third goes harold
and the indians have a two to nothing
lead as eddie rosario
has extended his hitting streak to eight
games
and he's now driven in 29 runs for the
year
yeah he's starting to warm up a little
bit had himself in a good hitter's count
turned on the ball and he drilled it in
the right center field gap
hernandez cuts it off two runs will
score you got a nice pitch out up
over the plate so hernandez and ramirez
score
boy is that ever a huge lift it sure is
i mean
one swing right there give you a two
nothing lead the blue jays have runners
on the corners with one out now santiago
espinal in the eighth spot trying to get
the blue jays on the board they're down
two to nothing
in the second let's see here three two
there's a change grounded to third
and the only play is to first a low
throw there dug out
grichik will come in to score and give
estimate
an rbi on the ground out and i'm
wondering if panic was moving on that
pitch the way that
uh miller did not have a play at second
base because
i think if he had they would have tried
to at least get the lead runner and yeah
i think buck that panic was running on
the play and that really helped the blue
jays there
yeah i think he was too on the full
count so they stay out of the double
play and
blue jays get on the board now danny
jansen hitting in the nine spot with the
runner with second two down top of the
second inning
and jansen lifts the fly ball left
center field it is carrying because of
the wind
and it's going to get beyond ramirez to
the fence
and into score on the play is panic that
ball just kept going
and going and riding the wind out to
left and it's an rbi double for jansen
to tie the game
yeah ramirez took a very shallow route
to that fall
and you got to know that the wind is
going to be challenging but look how
shallow he is he doesn't give any ground
and by the time he recognizes it it's
too late
the ball actually may have hit on the
grass short of the warning truck
and he just never really got there it
was a ball it took off but ramirez came
in too
shallow trying to go straight across
instead of playing safety first
back to the top of the order marcus
semion who's singled his first time up
through and by him good finish for eli
morgan here in the second inning
but the blue jays get a wind blown
double and tie the game
runner at first one down blue jays
batting third inning game tied at two
hernandez right field
and it's over the head of naylor he'll
play it off the wall on his way to third
is bushette
here's the throw to second gonna be a
close play and they got him
oh what a job by naylor and ahmed
rosario
to record the second out of the inning
boy that was a laser
it is pinball baseball tonight folks
that was a laser
off the wall and he did play it
perfectly
and you know he had to play in front of
him but he says i'm just going to go
anyway
i mean he sliced this ball to right
field but watch the hop
turns and throws you can tell he grew up
in canada
that's throwing a snowball of second
base and throwing a strike
beautiful play and the batter is randall
grichik
richik swings at the first pitch and he
drives one to right field
over the head of naylor the shed will
come in to score
grichik on his way into second and there
with a stand-up double
as the blue jays take a three to two
lead three runs on
six hits now for the blue jays and
here's lourdes gorilla
a change up hit in the air to left field
and hit well
and it's going to be off the wall
gretchek in to score
goriel on his way to second with a
double and the blue jays have a four to
two lead
here's joe panick singleton scored his
first time up here's the pitch
and he sends one deep to right field and
it is gone
panic turns on a fastball and hits it
way out to right and the blue jays now
leads six
to two first time run of the season for
joe panic and
second time through the order the blue
jays have been
timing up morgan very effectively
lots of good swings in this inning
and you mentioned the doubles and panic
gets another pitch right out over the
heart of the plate and morgan knew that
one's not going to stay in the yard
you just got to keep the ball out of the
middle of the plate i don't care how
hard you throw how soft you throw you
just can't leave that many balls over
the heart of the plate
what an inning for the blue jays second
and third nobody out situation another
3-2 pitch upcoming here to goriel
and he hits it sharply and fair inside
the bag at third and down the left field
line
hernandez into score gretchek in behind
him
it's a two-run double for goriel and
it's now eight to two for the blue jays
so now eight two blue jason here's joe
panic who's having a big night one two
on the way
and panic lying to the left center field
and that ball is down
guriel around third he'll come in to
score it'll be a long single by panic to
drive in another run and make it nine to
two
bases loaded two down here's santiago
espinal
one two and he lines it to right field
down the line a fair ball
guerrero to score guerrielle in to score
panic will be held at third a two-run
double for espinal
it is 11-2 for another beautiful swing
on a pitch away
as espinal stays on he gets his first
hit of the game
watch how he stays on this pitch it's up
and away and if he tries to pull that
pitch he's gonna roll over on it but he
stayed with it drives it the other way
picks up his fourth double of the season
now they're taking the blue jays off the
field yeah
i think we've seen the last to baseball
for tonight so i think this game is
over yep that's it this goes into the
books as an 11-2 win
for the blue jays